We learn best when we're learning from
content that we find interesting.
Comprehensible input or, as Stephen
Krashen, renowned expert on language...
language acquisition calls it, compelling
content. So, make sure you choose material,
choose lessons that interest you. You may
find them on your feed. These could be
lessons that other people at LingQ are
studying. It could be newspaper articles
that are regularly presented to you on
your feed. You may even want to import
,and you should familiarize yourself with
the different ways of importing lessons.
We have a... a Chrome extension and a
Google extension whereby you can... and
also a Firefox extension, so that you can
import anything you find on the web. This
is also available on your tablet. Make
sure you're familiar... you familiarize
yourself. You can also import ebooks into
LingQ, and if you're smart, find the
audiobook for it. So make sure you are
fully aware of how to bring interesting
content into your learning space. It's
going to help your learning.